vous êtes sur rtl
il est 18 heures 18 interview actualité
dans rtl soir thomas sotto vous recevez
bruno retailleau sénateur de la vendée
et président du groupe l'est républicain
au sénat un bon soir bruno retailleau
bonsoir thomas sotto après la tête de la
préfecture de police de paris il ya ceux
comme eric woerth qui parlent de
scandale d tu as eu comme guillaume
larrivé eric ciotti jean luc mélenchon
marine le pen jordan bardet l'avons qui
vont encore plus loin qui demande la
démission de christophe castaner bruno
retailleau est ce que c'est un procès
politique qui est fait à christophe
questionnaire où il ya aujourd'hui un
problème castaner en france il ya un
problème en france sur le point de
savoir si au plus haut niveau de l'état
on est déterminés ou pas à lutter contre
l'islam radical
le djihadisme bien sûr qu'il ya une
invraisemblable légèreté de la part du
ministre kassa neri dans n'est pas
d'ailleurs à ses débuts puisque vous
rappeler au moment des gilets jaunes ils
la fameuse soi-disante attacked la pitié
salpêtrière qui m'avait jamais il ya
quelques jours orman bien ça c'est une
chose mais ce qui est grave
ce que les français constate c'est que
il ya eu un terroriste islamiste qui a
produit un attentat abominable
monstrueux dans le coeur du coeur de
l'appareil de l'état censé lutter contre
le terrorisme islamiste
est-ce que ça c'est la responsabilité du
miz de l'intérieur en pur et clair
doit-il selon vous démissionnez j'ai
pour principe vous le savez de ne jamais
demander la démission du ministre le
concert mais ça concerne encore plus
emmanuel macron d'ailleurs à le jeu
l'adresse apps et emmanuel macron je
m'adresse aux auditeurs mails macron il
est partout on le voit partout il parle
surtout on n'a pas entendu sur wii on
n'a toujours pas il a dit qu'il irait on
ne l'a pas entendu sur cette affaire qui
est grave parce que elle met en cause la
sécurité de l'état vis-à-vis d'un
fonctionnaire de police qui étaient
accrédités au secret défense dont on ne
sait pas ce qu'il a pu faire
capter comme fichier qui contient
d'ailleurs les adresses personnelles
d'un certain nombre de nos propres
agents ni même s'il a pu implanter des
chevaux de troie sur un certain nombre
de logiciels saas et les autres qui va
le déterminer
l'enquêté est en cours je pense
aujourd'hui que le problème est le
suivant nous sommes engagés dans une
guerre c'est pas nous qui avons voulu la
guerre ce sont les ennemis qui vous
désigne nous livrons une guerre qui fait
des morts elle en a fait 92 en
afghanistan elle en a fait 29 je crois
barkan au mali mais la guerre elle est
aussi sur notre territoire
et aujourd'hui j'ai le sentiment qu'il y
a une formidable naïveté une naïveté
coupable d'état peut-être c'est un
scandale d'état
mais je pense que cette affaire montre y
compris d'ailleurs dans les conséquences
qui pour le moment ne sont pas tirés je
pense que cette affaire montrent qu' on
n'a pas un niveau d'exigence en matière
de combat contre le radicalisme
islamiste suffisant cette purée relève
du déni d'état et du mensonge d'état dit
marine le pen est d'accord avec ça en
tout cas
mensonge d'état en tout cas incompétence
en tout cas je pense que quand je dis
naïveté c'est que y'a si j'ose dire
deux phénomènes ya un phénomène qu'elle
djihadisme qui nous fascine qui nous
terrorisme par sa violence mais ce
phénomène il est couplé à une idéologie
frérot salafistes un islam radical
politique que je ne confonds pas avec
l'autre islam mais qui gangrène des
territoires qui conquiert des esprits et
des territoires et je pense que il faut
lutter contre l'un et l'autre ode nous
ne faisons pas la meilleure d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui vous dites à emmanuel macron
monsieur le président vous ne vous
attaquez pas à la menace islamiste en
france pas suffisamment et j'attends
j'attends une parole claire du président
de la république parce que c'est la
sécurité de l'état comment se fait-il
que ce poison islamiste qui s'est
infiltré au coeur de l'appareil de
l'état n'est pas engendré une prise de
parole vraiment du présent république
comment se fait-il par exemple que le
président du sénat qui sous l'ancien
quinquennat était systématiquement
contacté par le ministre l'intérieur
d'arabie ministres où le chef de l'état
lorsqu'il y avait un gros pépin un
attentat sur l'arche et au moment où je
vous parle n'a toujours pas été contacté
il ya quelque chose qui ne tourne pas
rond
et la question que je me pose c'est que
vous se dit quand même ce soir le
problème c'est pas castaner ces macro
non jatte jeudi
simplement moi je ne suis pas un fou
furieux des démissions je pense que
c'est extrêmement grave et je pense que
on doit demander aux hommes politiques
le sens de la responsabilité j'ai
entendu monsieur castanet redis je ne
suis pas personnellement responsable
enfin s'il n'est pas personnellement
responsable de son administration et des
failles
d'ailleurs c'est même pas un
dysfonctionnement j'ai entendu le mot
dysfonctionnement c'est une béance c'est
une faillite totale
encore une fois un terroriste islamiste
au coeur du dispositif anti islamiste ça
veut dire quoi donc j'attends du
président de république et le chef de
l'état qui est le patron des armées
puisque nous sommes et nous livrons un
combat qu'il s'exprime rapidement qu'est
ce qu'ils en pensent qu'elles le sont
ils voilà il ya quelques semaines la
fondation pour l'islam de france
invitait la ligue islamique mondiale
il ya eu je crois une polémique et du
coup ni premier ministre président de
république
ils sont allés donc oui ou non est ce qu
on veut combattre oui ou non c'est pas
une affaire de moyens
c'est une affaire de courage de fermeté
voilà et on entend votre appel lancé
emmanuel macron ce soir bruno retailleau
le débat sur l'immigration a lieu en ce
moment à l'assemblée nationale chez vous
au sénat ce sera après demain mercredi
on entendu tout à l'heure edouard
philippe dire qu'il était ouvert à
l'idée de quotas est ce que vous vous y
êtes favorable des quotas j'attendais
edouard philippe dire je veux bien
réfléchir aux côtes alors aujourd'hui il
veut bien réfléchi à l'immigration
demain il veut bien réfléchir aux quotas
mais quel courage je voudrais quand même
ça lui ce courage nous avions proposé au
moment de la présidentielle
vous êtes un observateur avisé justement
que chaque année le parlement puisse
voter des quotas notamment sur le quota
de travail par métier et c'est donc bien
sûr je pense moi que tout le problème
aujourd'hui c'est que et c'est pas moi
qui le dit marcel gaucher de la cride
ans dans plusieurs articles et est dans
un livre le phénomène migratoire a
profondément bouleversé notre société or
ce phénomène migratoire a été mise à
l'écart de la délibération des peuples
et je pense que ont fait cesser la
démagogie ou quand l'aide justement la
démocratie reprend ses droits et moi je
veux que la notion de vote la notion de
démocratie reprenne ses droits je veux
que chaque année le parlement devant le
peuple français puisse voter non pas
d'ailleurs des quotas mais des plafonds
d'immigration pour que
fin on puisse avoir une politique
migratoire et en matière de droit
d'asile des plafonds en tout cas
j'observe que l'allemagne par un accord
de la grande coalition du 1er août 2010
8 a restreint le droit au regroupement
familial
nous on a fait l'inversé le texte de
monsieur mais là où le droit d'asile est
ce qu'il faut le restreindre selon vous
le droit des affaires ou droit le
restreint non pas avec un plafond mais
en éliminant par exemple des gens qui
viennent les demandes de gens qui
viennent de pays sûr je pense aux
albanais je pense aux géorgiens ils ont
des gros demandeurs d'asile sans qui
sont valables dès parmi les premiers de
vendeurs d'asie mais emmanuel macron a
reconnu son échec
il a reconnu il ya un mois devant les
ambassadeurs à la conférence des
ambassadeurs
il a reconnu son échec en disant que la
france était désormais le premier pays
européen de rebond des déboutés du droit
d'asile
on en est là donc ça c'est pas un mot qu
elle il faut s'attaquer selon vous un
manager qui n'ad'autre sais pas si
j'étais bien réveillé bruno retailleau
mais j'ai cru vous entendre dire à la
radio que vous n'excluez pas d'être
candidat à la présidentielle j'ai bien
entendu c'est une hypothèse vous disais
que je vois très réveillés
thomas sotto vous aviez l'habitude a
l'habitude de matinée explique très tôt
il est d'accord je réponde à une
question disant mais voilà est-ce que
vous serez candidat ou pas je vis ici
mes convictions sont portés sur
quelqu'un d'autre avec vous le suivrez
tiendrais et sinon votre question je
m'interrogerais d'accord donc si demain
vous étiez aux responsabilités voire au
sommet de l'état est-ce que vous
reviendriez sur la pma pour tout qui va
sans doute être votée bruno retailleau
on a vu la manifestation d'hier soixante
quinze mille personnes selon les
comptages neutre est-ce que vous
reviendriez là dessus n'attendez moi je
vais faire en sorte qu'elle ne soit pas
votée les députés ont voté une partie du
texte ça va venir au sénat ça reviendra
à l'assemblée
moi je vais essayer de l'éviter c'était
une question ce qui est important c'est
comme le mariage pour tous il ya ceux
qui voulaient revenir dessus qu'ils
l'ont jamais fait ce choix je pense que
c'est une mauvaise chose
tout simplement parce que on doit
répondre à cette question oui ou non
pense-t-on que pour un enfant c'est
neutre de ne pas avoir de père moi je
pense qu'à tout le moins on peut pas
répondre définitivement à cette question
et à macao est ce que voulait bien
répondre à ma question est ce que vous
reviendrez et jeu
vous me la reposerez lorsque je serai
candidat aux présidentielles instance
les dernières petites questions sur une
autre candidature il ya des élections
chez les républicains chez vous premier
tour le week-end prochain
vous votez christian jacob guillaume
larrivé ou julien aubert très rapidement
parce qu'on est obligés passe où tu j'en
ai soutenu aucun je me suis pas
présentée je vous demande au tas et les
visées bien je voterai voilà je voterai
discrètement je voterai pas ce que c'est
a toutefois c'est un soutien discret
mais non mais je suis président de
groupe si ce soir guidon bravo tonnes
quand vous étiez président de groupe
vous souteniez à monsieur de capter
françois fillon et vous en cachez non
non non non vous avez tort je n'avais
pas pris position au moment de
l'élection du président de l air qui
avait bruno le maire y avait nicolas
sarkozy j'avais tenu la même ligne je
pense que pour une affaire partisane et
interne si aujourd'hui ce soir jeudi à
votre antenne qui est à s'écouter me dis
tant que je vais l'offrir long sur la
joie mais sénateurs pourraient le
prendre pour une sorte de consignes mais
je pense qu'aujourd'hui la famille est
trop dispersée pour que je prenne ce
risque là j'aime beaucoup christian
jacob a dit nicolas sarkozy dans mes
christian jacob est quelqu'un de bien et
ils n'étaient que deux lots à désirer
qui les deux autres allez monsieur
l'arrivée et j'ai mis à opera place est
bon merci beaucoup bruno retailleau
d'être venus se former